to someone first encountering the works
of William Shakespeare the language may
seem strange but there is a secret to
appreciating it although he was famous
for his plays
Shakespeare was first and foremost a
poet one of the most important things in
Shakespeare's language is his use of
stress not that kind of stress but the
way we emphasize certain syllables in
words more than others we're so used to
doing this that we may not notice it at
first but if you say the words slowly
you can easily identify them playwright
computer telephone poets are very aware
of these stresses having long
experimented with the number and order
of stressed and unstressed syllables and
combined them in different ways to
create rhythm in their poems like
songwriters poets often express their
ideas through a recognizable repetition
of these rhythms or poetic meter and
like music poetry has its own set of
terms for describing this in a line of
verse a foot is a certain number of
stressed and unstressed syllables
forming a distinct unit just as a
musical measure consists of a certain
number of beats one line of verse is
usually made up of several feet for
example a dactyl is a metrical foot of
three syllables with the first stressed
and the second and third unstressed that
tools can create lines that move swiftly
and gather force as in Robert Browning's
poem the lost leader just for a handful
of silver he left us just for a ribbon
to stick in his coat another kind of
foot is the two syllable long trokey a
stressed syllable followed by an
unstressed one the trophy's in these
lines from Shakespeare's Macbeth lend an
ominous and spooky tone to the witch's
chant double double toil and trouble
fire burn and cauldron bubble
but with Shakespeare it's all about the
I am this two syllable foot is like a
reverse stroke II so the first syllable
is unstressed and
second is stressed as in to be or not to
be Shakespeare's favorite meter in
particular was I am big pentameter where
each line of verse is made up of five
two syllable ions for a total of ten
syllables and it's used for many of
Shakespeare's most famous lines shall I
compare thee to a summers day arise fair
Sun and kill the envious moon
notice how the ions cut across both
punctuation and word separation meter is
all about sound not spelling
I am b'keen tomato may sound technical
but there's an easy way to remember what
it means the word I am is pronounced
just like the phrase I am now let's
expand that to a sentence that just
happens to be in iambic pentameter I am
a pirate with a wooden leg the pirate
can only walk in AIIMS
a living reminder of Shakespeare's
favorite meter I am big pond Tomita is
when he takes ten steps our pirate
friend can even help us remember how to
properly mark it if we imagine the
footprints he leaves walking along a
deserted island Beach a curve for
unstressed syllables and a short line
for stressed ones if music be the food
of love play on
of course most lines of Shakespeare's
plays are written in regular prose but
if you read carefully you'll notice that
Shakespeare's characters turned to
poetry and iambic pentameter in
particular for many of the same reasons
that we look to poetry in our own lives
feeling passionate introspective or
momentous whether it's Hamlet pondering
his existence on Romeo professing his
love the characters switched to iambic
pentameter when speaking about their
emotions and their place in the world
which leaves just one last question why
did Shakespeare choose I Amba
contaminents rather than say trochaic
hexameter or dactylic tetrameter it's
been said that I am big pan tomate er
was easy for his actors to memorize and
for the audience to understand
because it's naturally suited to the
English language but there might be
another reason the next time you're in a
heightened emotional situation like the
ones that make Shakespeare's characters
burst into verse put your hand over the
left side of your chest what do you feel
that's your heart beating in AIIMS dum
there dum dai dum dai dum dai dum dai
Quiroz paretic lines don't just talk
about matters of the heart they follow
its rhythm